then we're in the past I don't need to
wear wear at the public because of not
within six feet of anybody though I've
got one here dude pocket but there's the
surgical mask and that's because the
White House has got its own little hot
spot here on Friday the press secretary
to Vice President Mike Pence Katie
Miller tested positive and she was in
contact they call a low risk contact Oh
with Maria the top US officials regarded
the coronavirus we talked about she dr.
Robert Redfield who's the head of the
Centers for Disease Control dr. Stephen
Hahn who's the head of the Food and Drug
Administration and of course because she
is married
the president is top domestic policy
adviser Stephen Miller all of those
people now are not working where they're
supposed to work they are at home in
self-isolation dr. Fauci dr. Redfield
dr. Hahn and atrovent renoir who is the
assistant secretary of HHS will be
appearing before the Senate although
however none of them will be up on
Capitol Hill person they will be
participating in the intelligent work so
good to hear a lot about all of that in
the next hour here at the White House
rose garden
correct and one of the one of the points
that the president is going to make
today is that in the month of May the
federal government through a partnership
with the governors will provide every
state with the capability to test more
people than South Korea tested that's
out of the capita basis Horstman South
Korea was sort of held up as the gold
standard for testing early on in this
coronavirus pandemic now the white house
will say across the nation all 50 states
have got the same capability to test the
same number of people per capita South
Korea did but don't forget Korea was
South Korea was doing that eight weeks
ago here we are now in
color-wise all right we're both
right
right
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
thank you very much thank you we're here
today to provide an update on the
unprecedented testing capacity developed
by the United States the most advanced
and robust testing system anywhere in
the world by far this afternoon I'll
also announced new steps that we're
taking to make tests even more widely
available to battle a virus my
administration marshaled every resource
at our nation's disposal public private
military economic scientific and
industrial all at your disposal we
launched the largest manufacturing
ramped up since the Second World War
there's been nothing like it since at
the center of this industrial and
scientific mobilization was the
development of our corona virus testing
capabilities in the span of just a few
short months we've developed a testing
capacity unmatched and unrivaled
anywhere in the world and it's not even
close this is a core element of our plan
to safely and gradually reopen America
and we're opening and we're starting and
there's enthusiasm like I haven't seen
in a long time every American should be
proud of the amazing array of talent
skill and enterprise our nation is
brought to this challenge in three
months the FDA has authorized more than
92 different tests and over nine million
have been performed here in the United
States three weeks ago we were
conducting roughly 150,000 tests per day
now we're doing approximately 300,000
tests per day a 100% increase and it
will go up substantially from that
number this week the United States will
pass 10 million tests conducted nearly
double the number of any other country
we're testing more people per capita
than South Korea the United Kingdom
France Japan Sweden Finland Finland and
many other countries and in some cases
combined on Friday the FDA authorized
coronavirus antigen test and alternative
testing technology that can be much more
readily man
a faction qui del corporation which
makes this newly authorized
point-of-care test estimates that it
will be able to manufacture 150 thousand
tests per day immediately increasing to
three hundred thousand tests per day
within just a few weeks to further
expand our nation's testing capabilities
this afternoon I am announcing that my
administration is in and we've got this
all approved that's all done is sending
1 billion dollars to America's States
territories and tribes so this has all
been approved we've gotten it done
completed the money is going out this
major investment will ensure that
America continues to conduct more tests
than any country on Earth by far I said
from the beginning that the federal
government would back up the states and
help them build their testing capability
and capacities and that's exactly what's
happened this partnership has truly
flourished we have really had a very
good relationship with the states and
the governors and other representatives
within the states a relationship like I
think I can honestly say has not been
seen in this country for many many years
the governors and us are working
together very closely not only in
testing but on ventilators where we have
a capacity that's at this point
virtually unlimited and we're sending
ventilators as you probably heard from
other countries we're sending many many
thousands of ventilators to other
countries because they're in tremendous
need and I think building up a lot of
goodwill but much more importantly than
that we're saving a lot of lives most
states are now doing a great job my
administration located 5,000 machines
and 700 labs across all 50 states and
governors have learned how to maximize
these testing resources the federal
government is also supporting States
with vital supplies quick approvals of
new tests and one-on-one coaching from
the team here at the White House on how
to increase capacity and increase it
very quickly in recent weeks we've held
multiple conference calls with every
state as well as with DC and
Arica we jointly develop testing
projections and goals for each state for
the month of May all together totaling
twelve point nine million tests think of
that twelve point nine million tests
today I'm announcing that my
administration will provide the
collection supplies to help States meet
their targets and meet them rapidly
during the month of May FEMA and HHS
will be delivering twelve point nine
million swabs to states nationwide we
already have them the delivery will be
very quick we're prepared to provide
millions of administration will also
provide approximately nine million
transport media which are used to
transfer swabs to the lab processing a
complicated process but we've made it
simple as a result of these actions
every single state will be able to test
more people per capita in May alone then
South Korea has tested in four months
since the outbreak began this major
commitment is possible because of the
massive mobilization of American
industry including Puritan medical
products u.s. cotton Abbott Labs and
thermo Fisher some of these incredible
companies produced sand produced rapidly
for us and their products are here with
us this afternoon these are all
different products that were literally
just developed and if you can imagine
that and these are the best machines and
the best equipment anywhere in the world
and other countries are calling us and
we're trying to work as much as we can
not only on ventilators but also with
testing my administration also continues
our tireless effort to expand testing in
the most underserved communities through
our partnership with the private sector
leading pharmacies and retailers are now
operating over 240 testing sites across
the country and that's in addition to
all of the other sites that we have
working 70 percent of these sites are
located in communities with unique
vulnerabilities there will be more than
300 sites by the end of this week and
retailers are making plans to open up
hundreds and hundreds more locations
within the next 30 days these additional
sites are helping us since your access
testing in every community my
administration is fighting relentlessly
to protect all citizens of every color
and Creed from this terrible virus the
invisible enemy in addition to vast
amounts of testing supplies my
administration is partnered with the
private sector to coordinate the
delivery of more than 90 million n95
masks and these are of the highest
quality many are made right here in the
United States at capacity we didn't have
it all at the beginning 126 million
surgical masks likewise many are made
here nine million face shields 21
million surgical gowns nine hundred
ninety three million gloves and ten
thousand six hundred ninety ventilators
were building thousands of ventilators
in numerous plants all across our
country it's incredible actually this
global pandemic has inflicted great pain
and hardship on our people it should
have never been allowed to happen it
should have been stopped at the source
we mourn for every life the virus has
claimed and we share the grief of all of
the you who've lost a loved one and that
goes worldwide to many many countries
184 countries at least thanks to the
courage of our citizens and our
aggressive strategy hundreds of
thousands of lives have been saved and
we have saved and if you look at on a
per 100,000 basis we're at the best part
of the pack right on the bottom Germany
and us are leading the world Germany and
the United States are leading the world
live saved per hundred thousand in every
generation through every challenge and
hardship and danger America has risen to
the task we have met the moment and we
have prevailed Americans do whatever it
takes to find solutions pioneer
breakthroughs and harness the energies
we need to achieve a total victory day
after day we're making tremendous
strides with the dedication of our
doctors and nurses these are incredible
people these are brave people these are
warriors with the devotion of our
manufacturing workers
food suppliers and lab technicians and
with the profound patriotism of the
American people we will defeat this
horrible enemy we will revive our
economy and we will transition into
greatness that's a phrase you're gonna
hear a lot because that's what's going
to happen we're going into the third
quarter and we're gonna do well in the
fourth quarter we're gonna do very good
and next year I think we're gonna have
one of the best years we've ever had
because there's a tremendous pent up
demand it's a demand and I'm feeling it
I've felt things alot over in my life
and I've made a lot of good calls it's a
demand like I don't think I've ever seen
there's a pent-up demand as a there's a
spirit in this country like few have
seen and I think you can say and we've
helped a lot of the countries a lot
really a lot there's a tremendous spirit
all over the world to beat this terrible
terrible thing but we're transitioning
to greatness and the greatness is going
to be in the fourth quarter but it's
really going to be next year and it's
going to be a year like we've never had
before I really believe that as good as
we've done and we've done great we had
the best economy in the history of the
world not just here but anywhere in the
world you can talk Jana you can talk any
other country we had the best economy
anywhere in the world and we were going
for numbers weather was unemployment
numbers well we had our best numbers
employment also numbers a little
different where we had our best numbers
almost a hundred and sixty million
people all of that we had the greatest
stock market numbers ever I think we
don't ever I think we're hundred and
forty-two days where we set records in a
short period of time a hundred and
fifty-two days we set records in the
stock market we rebuilt our military all
built in the United States all of our
equipment built one point five trillion
dollars plus on the southern border the
wall is being built it's being built
rapidly and now you don't hear the
opponent's talking too much about the
border they don't like to talk about it
because it seemed that we were right on
a lot of things one
the things we were right about one of
the many things was the border we have a
very powerful border now we had one of
the best weeks in the history of our
border between the United States and
Mexico our southern border we had very
few people coming in very very few
almost record low numbers and the wall
is being built it's up to 181 miles
already it's being built it's being
built rapidly people don't talk about it
anymore because it's very successful in
the area where the wall has built that
is a lot still but we want to be up to
450 by very short period of time early
next year we should be up to 450 and
very shortly after that over 500 miles
to be completed but it's had a
tremendous impact but again we've had
the best numbers the last thing we want
now with this pandemic is for people to
come across our southern border and
again we're doing record numbers meaning
record low numbers so I just want to
thank everybody and I want to introduce
Admiral guar if you could please come up
and bread if you would bread Smith and
they're going to do a little explaining
as to what we've done with regard to
testing and how successful it's been and
then we'll take some questions after
that thank you very much well thank you
mr. president for your leadership and
for your high expectations that really
made this all come together and for the
uniform support of everyone in the White
House and the administration and Thank
You secretary azar for providing his
leadership at HHS and allowing both Brad
and I the opportunity to work on this
project I think it's clear that America
does lead the world in testing I'll go
through some of the charts that show
that we lead quantitatively I will also
suggest that we lead in the diversity of
tests which are very important to
establish the testing ecosystem to keep
America safe and clearly as we've said
multiple times no one beats America when
it comes to quality so let's start
potentially with the next slide this may
be hard to see but if you look at the
line on top that's the total numbers of
tests
by the United States no other country in
the world comes close to the total
numbers again as the president has said
today we will top over 9 million tests
and if you look at per capita everyone
talks about South Korea being the
standard today we will have done more
than twice their per capita rate of
testing that was accomplished in South
Korea no matter how you look at it
America is leading the world in testing
and how did we get there let's look at
the next slide next slide please
a very important component of how we
came to this point was the authorization
by the FDA under the leadership of our
secretary of many different diagnostic
tests of diagnostic devices and now of
serology tests so you've heard a lot
about the different testing and you see
some of the machines up here most of the
diagnostic tests all but one rely on the
amplification of the viral RNA the viral
nucleic material and we've talked to you
about the diversity of tests they're
very high throughput tests that are done
at big reference labs like LabCorp and
quest but very importantly there are
also tests and you heard us talk about
Cepheid delivering over 2 million tests
vitally important to rural America's
into places that do not have very large
infrastructure you've also seen the
Abbott test we've talked about there it
is on the left of the president
delivering about 1.4 million tests as a
point of care test you get the result
within 5 to 15 minutes and we have
deployed over 235 thousand of these
tests to the state public health
laboratories in every state of this
country to make sure that that point of
care testing capability is there to
research outbreaks like in nursing homes
or in certain industrial capacities and
well over 90,000 to the Indian Health
Service so they could test at a point of
care in remote locations
the president also talked about a new
first in-class test it's listed there as
an antigen based test this is very
important and you've heard ambassador
birx talk about this multiple times
because antigen testing although complex
is much less complex than the nucleic
acid testing that we've had
Cadell had this authorized by the FDA
and as the president said we'll soon be
making over 300,000 tests per day do the
math that's nine million point-of-care
tests that we will have every month in
just a few weeks it will clearly add to
into a certain degree transform our
landscape which you don't see up here is
the important work the FDA did I'm a
swab guy now I'm very interested in
swabs in order to make all these tests
work you have to show that a certain
swab made of a certain material
performed in a certain way delivers a
highly accurate result and what you're
seeing up here is some of the fruits of
that labor without the authorizations of
for example the foam nasal swab we would
be blowing through PPE all across the
country because of the need for full PPE
just to take a test that has really been
changed by this diverse authorization
and a recent authorization allows the
great manufacturer u.s. cotton to join
our foundational injury industry of
puritan next slide
last week we did over 1.9 million tests
and that number is growing and again as
the president said and Brad will talk
about our state's aspired to do well
over 12 million tests over the next four
weeks you see the graph growing which
you also see very importantly is that
little orange bar on the bottom is the
cumulative number of positives our
percent positives are going down and
that's what we want to see in fact in 31
States as of last night the positivity
rate is less than 10 percent which is
not a litmus test but is a good idea
that we're doing plenty enough testing
that we can enter phase 1 for careful
reopening I also want to take the
opportunity to say this doesn't happen
by accident
I'm seeing everyone in the audience here
and I'm so pleased that they can be here
people
sitting in the front have been working
literally 18 to 20 hours a day every
single day of the week for at least the
past two months none of this happens by
accident it happens because their hard
work their sacrifice their sacrifice of
their family all for a common good and
I'm very very honored to consider to you
all as my colleagues in my last slide as
the president said 11 billion dollars
are now being announced to be delivered
to the States for the sole support of
testing this will give them the
resources to partner as they have with
the federal government with the
president the vice president the task
force with Brad and I to achieve their
testing goals and we're gonna be very
specific and they know it that there
needs to be minimum numbers to be
planned to test they have to have plans
for their vulnerable communities
including nursing homes including those
who are disabled including those are in
prisons or who have working environments
that they may have a more likelihood to
spread the infection and combined with
that it's the secretary's office of
minorities health will soon be awarding
a large contract to guarantee a national
network of state local and
community-based organizations to assure
that those underserved particularly
racial and ethnic minorities are linked
to the surfaces they need not only
testing but in care as well and with
that I'd like to hand it over to Brad
Smith who's the director of the Center
for Medicare and Medicaid innovation but
has really been the chief operating
officer to make all of this come
together Brad
Thank You Admiral I want to talk through
a little bit specifically the work that
we've been doing with the states so as
the Admiral mentioned over the past few
weeks we've been working with each state
to set a target for their testing goal
for me over the series of a couple of
different calls we've aligned on what
those goals are and as the Admiral
mentioned in the president mentioned
they add up to over 12 point nine
million tests in the month of May for
every state this is greater than two
percent of their population in the
entire state being tested in May and for
many states it's a much higher
more than that when you compare this as
the president mentioned to South Korea
South Korea is actually below that 2%
not for a month but for their total test
to date since the start of the year and
so our states have come together to set
really ambitious goals that were excited
to support them in meeting if you go to
the next slide as I talked about last
time in the press briefing there are
really three parts to making sure that a
test can happen the first part is the
specimen collection supplies the second
part is the machines and the third part
are the lab supplies that the machines
need to run and what we've been working
to do is to make sure that each state
has all three of those parts to be able
to conduct the number of tests the first
part is the specimen collection supplies
the commercial market today is providing
a large number of these supplies are
ready to States and are ready to
hospitals but we wanted to ensure that
every state had more than what they
needed to be able to conduct a number of
tests they're aiming in May so what
we've done is we've purchased enough
tests to support the state testing goals
for May and June so we will be sending
more than twelve point nine million
swabs and over ten million media to the
States over the course of May and a
similar a greater number over the course
of June in addition we have several
million in reserve so if states are able
to exceed their goal in the third and
fourth week of May we can provide them
even more slobs and transport media and
again this is in addition to what's
already available in the commercial
market if you go to the next slide there
are large numbers have been talked about
many times a large number of testing
machines across the country over 5,000
different machines that can conduct
these tests the key part is making sure
that the machines and that the labs have
enough supplies to run the machines
there will be in the month of May
commercially produced over 25 million
test kits which is either the PCR and
extraction kits or the cartridges to be
able to support tests and they're in
their effort it states in their testing
effort and what we've been working to do
with each state is understand their
total goal and each of the manufacturers
has been a great partner with us and
told us how many tests they're shipping
to each lab in each state over the
course of May and what we know is that
in the aggregate the number of tests
gives the state is getting is greater
than their testing goal for the month of
May in addition to what the states have
already purchased there's over
seven million additional tests that
remain unpurchased the majority of those
from thermo Fisher which is the most
common machine in the country so we feel
very confident the states will not only
have the specimen collection supplies
and the machines but also the extraction
kits and the reagents they need to be
able to hit or potentially exceed their
testing goals and if you go to the last
slide the last piece of the puzzle is
making sure that Americans had access to
these tests healthcare providers
hospitals primary care physicians are
already providing these tests to date
and we for the past six or seven weeks
have been partnered with the retailers
who have massively been ramping up their
effort today there are over 240 retail
sites we've been working with the
retailer's to make sure that they're
specifically targeting low-income and
other vulnerable communities across the
country and we're talking with them
about potentially opening more than
another thousand additional sites over
the next month or two so we hope that
we've put together the right pieces of
the puzzle having access points for
patients and Americans across the
country having the specimen collection
supplies needed to take the test
having the machines and then also having
the lab testing supplies with the
machines so thank you very much thank
you very much maybe you'll both stay
there could be some questions okay
please John go ahead you can't hear me
we had a situation here at the White
House on Friday
where a member of the vice president's
staff tested positive for corona virus
which is now class three of the top US
officials involved in the corona virus
response to self isolate two-part
question where did the system break down
to allow that to happen and where what
would you say to employers to look at
the experience here at the White House
and say are we ready for this I don't
think the system broke down at all and
one person tested positive surprisingly
because the previous day tested negative
and three people that were in contact
relative contact who I believe they've
all tested totally negative but they are
going to for a period of time self
isolate so that's not breaking down it
can happen it's the hidden enemy
remember that it's the hidden enemy so
things happen but the three tested
negative
the one who tested positive will be fine
it will be absolutely fine yeah John hey
president to do other companies who may
look at this and say I don't know if
we're ready for all well I think you
know we have a lot of people at the
White House and we had one basically we
had one person so we had a lot of people
that work here this building is shocking
if you looked at the numbers and it's
also tremendous numbers of people coming
in normally you wouldn't do that
but because we're running a country we
want to keep our country running so we
have a lot of people coming in and out
many of those people most of those
people are tested depending on what
portion of the oval office area they're
going in everybody coming in to the
president's office gets tested and I
felt no vulnerability whatsoever Jen but
the two people as I said and three
people are they have been tested and
it's negative and they'll be probably
out of quarantine very quickly okay John
if I can follow up on that your staff
your senior staff is you just referenced
is able to get tested every day when
will it be that Americans across the
country will be able to get tested every
day as they go back to work very soon I
mean really very soon it's an
interesting question because normally
you would have said that you are not
tested and you would have been you know
knocking us for not getting tested so if
we get tested it's a problem and if we
don't get tested it's a problem but I
like the way your question was phrased
better this way because it is a positive
we are tested we have great capability
you look at all of these machines here
they're incredible machines is that the
best anywhere in the world no place in
the world has this kind of equipment
other countries are calling
sophisticated countries and they're
calling lots of countries and we're
trying to make as much as we can
available to them because there's
nothing like what we've been able to do
in a literally a couple of months what
they've been able to do the private
sector what they how they got it done
this is a five to fifteen minute test as
an example the Abbott Laboratories test
these tests are highly sophisticated
very quick very good this is things that
didn't even exist a short while ago so
we do have a great testing capability at
the White House we're doing
and I think generally speaking we had a
call with the governor's the other day
generally speaking without exception
they were all extremely happy with
what's going on with respect to their
testing Tetrick what should people be
told to go back to work until they have
that assurance that they and their
co-workers are able to get out which
we're still not there we're leaving that
up to the governor's as you know and if
we see something wrong we'll call them
out and we'll stop it but we are leaving
it up to the governor's some are being
not aggressive enough in my opinion and
some are being a little bit aggressive
but they're being very careful and the
people of the country they've learned a
lot over the last two months
they've learned about social distancing
and washing your hands and other things
that we've all learned and talked about
they've learned about I see everybody
just about everybody has a face mask on
they've learned about face masks the
good and the bad by the way it's not a
one-sided thing believe it or not but
our country has learned our country has
been incredible and you see the numbers
they're dropping very substantially the
numbers are dropping around our country
very very substantially so we leave that
john up to the governors and i think
they're making a lot of good decisions
we've had as I said a great relationship
with governor's Democrat and Republican
and I think overall they're making very
good decisions
nobody in this group all the ones behind
the rope that's interesting
please Thank You mr. president you said
in your comments earlier we have met the
moment we have prevailed to you sir is
the mission accomplished even with one
point no we've prevailed on testing is
what I'm referring to that was with
regard to testing you never prevail when
you have 90,000 people a hundred
thousand people when you have 80
thousand people as of today when you
have this the kind of death you're
talking about when you have potentially
millions of people throughout the world
that are dying that's not prevalent what
I'm talking about is we have a great
testing capacity now it's getting even
better
there's nobody close to us in the world
and we certainly have done a great job
on testing and testing is a big is a
very big important function by the way
some people consider it more important
than others to be honest with you but
testing certainly is a very important
function and we have prevailed we have
the best equipment anywhere in the world
ok please yeah there are a variety of
reports that Chinese hackers are
attempting to steal technology related
to vaccine research is this something
you're concerned about what can you say
so what else is new with China what else
is doing tell me I'm not happy with
China they should have stopped this at
the source they could have stopped it
right at the source so now you're
telling me to hack in so I just say this
Steve what else is new well once you get
very closely yeah if I could follow up
sir the South China Morning Post the
Beijing newspaper says that China would
like to reopen negotiations on the trade
deal to make the terms more favorable to
them is this something you'd be
interested in doing no not at all not
even a little bit no I'm not interested
we signed a deal I had heard that too
they'd like to reopen the trade talk to
make it a better deal for them China's
been taking advantage of the United
States for many many years for decades
because we had people at this position
right here where I'm standing sitting
right in that office the Oval Office
allowed that to happen no I'm not
interested in that let's see if they
live up to the deal that they signed
okay please go ahead mr. president what
are your thoughts about a second round
of direct payments to Americans that's
included in the the House Democratic
bill well we're talking about that with
a lot of different people I want to see
a payroll tax cut I want to see various
things that we want I want the workers
to be taken care of but we are talking
about that we're negotiating with the
Democrats we'll see what happens but as
I said it's a transition and it's a this
is really going to be in my opinion
we'll see but I think it's going to be
something that's going to be very
special it's a transition to greatness
and greatness is next year right from
the beginning I think we're going to do
fantastically well I view the third
quarter as I said as a transition
quarter it could be pretty good but a
transition quarter toward the end of the
fourth quarter you're going to see some
numbers that are going to be tremendous
I think and next year you're going to
have potentially the kind of numbers
that you saw before and maybe even
better because there is that pent-up
demand that is you know a lot of people
wanted to do things they were ready to
do things and they've had to hold back
because of the virus so I think you're
gonna have with that pent up demand a
phenomenal year next year unless
somebody messes it up by coming along
and raising taxes doubling tripling
quadrupling your taxes like a certain
party namely the Democrats want to do
you'll mess it all up you know we had
the greatest in the world I presided
this administration presided over it it
got great for a reason and we'll do it
again and we'll do it again very quickly
and very easily I see that happening yes
ma'am please
Thank You mr. president almost everyone
as you noted in the Rose Garden is
wearing a mask today why haven't you
required everyone at the White House to
wear masks before now well if there's
certain distance from me or there are
certain distance from each other they do
in the case of me I'm not I'm not close
to anybody I'd like to be close to these
two gentlemen they're hard-working great
men but they just said frankly let's
keep it this way so obviously in my case
I'm very far away from everyone but if
you look at all of those people over
there every one of them from what I see
these are White House staffers they're
White House representatives they're
White House executives and everybody has
a mask on we've had just about everybody
I've seen today has worn a mask yeah are
you required that sir yeah I did I did I
required it yes please get one at some
point soon can you give us some figures
on what you're changing to ramp up
testing wind will that be a true
statement exactly and how exactly are
you going to accomplish that what's a
true statement already we have more
testing than any country in the world by
far but I'll let Admiral go into a
little bit of the future when you look
at the testing numbers that we worked
with collaboratively with with the state
leadership it's not just with the
governor but the state health officers
the state epidemiologist the public
health labs it's really a combination of
testing those who need something for
diagnosis diagnostic testing tracing so
testing those who have been around the
people with a diagnosis but the largest
fraction of that is really moving into
surveillance that is testing those who
are asymptomatic and when you do the
numbers this amount of testing on a
state to state basis really is in the
range that we need to accomplish all of
that certainly within the range that we
need so it really encompasses those
three things the other thing I would say
is particularly as we move into the
summer there are surveillance mechanisms
and I talked about them before like a
weather radar and just think about that
weather radar on the influence
like illness Network which is at about
75% of hot of health care institutions
and syndromic surveillance so if we see
a blip on that weather radar combined
with CDC personnel in every single state
and with contact tracers we really run
to the fire right and that's when you
detect you trace and you shut off that
outbreak right when it starts seems to
be a double standard here mr. president
where members of your own staff can get
tests frequently when they need it but
ordinary Americans cannot so when will
the rest of America have the same access
that members of your own White House
have to testing and you know what if we
didn't get the tests if we did no tests
in the White House should be up
complaining why aren't you getting tests
for the White House see we can't win
because if we didn't get the test you'd
be up I understand you very well better
than you understand yourself and frankly
if we didn't get tests done you'd be up
complaining about the fact that we
didn't have the test set now that we're
doing so well on tests and so quick and
so fast
five minutes etc and so accurate you're
complaining that we're getting too many
tests so you can't win go ahead Phil
yeah if the president many Americans
want to return to their normal lives but
they're afraid to do so how can you
ensure Americans that it's safe to go to
their own workplaces when the most
secure workplace in the country the
White House cannot contain the spread of
the corona virus it's infected some of
your own staff well when you say some so
we have a person and the person got
something happened right after a test
was done three other people met that
person came into relative contact very
little contact and their self quarantine
that is not exactly not controlling it
we I think we've controlled it very well
we have hundreds and hundreds of people
a day pouring into the White House it's
a massive office complex including the
very large building right behind us that
you know so well so I think we're really
doing a very good job in in watching it
and I think it's very well contained
actually and part of the reason it is
because of all the tests were able to
give but it was one person and the other
people were only people there
quarantined you understand this fill
their quarantine
for specific reason the reason is they
were in the general proximity of the one
person and the one person I believe will
be fine in a very short period of time
hasn't vice president Pence followed the
CDC guidelines of self-isolation and and
other people who might have been exposed
well that I'm gonna have to ask that he
will give you that information whatever
he is proceeding and doing he will give
you that information I'll make sure that
they put out a notice John go ahead
please mr. president up until now it's
thought that the most vulnerable people
were those above the age of 60 or 70 or
80 and the children were pretty much I
don't want to say immune from this but
weren't affected by it but all day long
in the news today we have been hearing
and seeing this terrible syndrome yeah
it's some 85 children have now three of
them have died what is the task force
talking about in terms of that and and
what could be done about yeah we're
seeing that all over the world down with
young children very very tiny percentage
but it's still it's the swelling and the
skin rash and we're looking at that very
closely John it's a phenomena that's
just been brought to everyone's
attention a couple of weeks ago and when
you may have something to say about that
so thank you for pointing that out and
again I've said many times I'm a
pediatrician and a pediatric ICU doctor
on this syndrome which we call or
similar to Kawasaki syndrome it has been
seen in a novel coronavirus before and
it's associated with illnesses so we
have a very strong activation on this we
do know treatments for this but the CDC
is act is interacting actively with the
pediatric intensive care unit network to
create case definitions and to
understand how this is going and if
their predispositions the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute I spoke to dr.
Gary Gibbons who directs that who is
advancing many research projects based
on that the asper the assistant
secretary for preparedness and response
has a team out in several areas looking
at if there are any special treatments
we know what the basic treatment is but
this is a little bit different than we
normally see so there really is an
activation among all the branches within
HHS working with networks at children's
hospitals and ICU nets it is a small
percentage but it is quite frightening
and this reflects the fact that this
virus affects the vasculature we see
clotting we see strokes and this is a
vasculature phenomena of inflammation we
see in children with this newly emerging
syndrome
now among young children what do you say
to parents who would like to get their
children back to school but are now with
looking at this and potentially afraid
to do that well again it's a tiny
percentage but you're right so we're
looking into it very strongly and the
Admiral as he said he's known about this
for long before this happened but it is
a very very small percentage and people
recover from that the children recover
from that right yes sir most do recover
from this but it is a it is a serious
and it can be a fatal condition so we do
want to make sure that parents
understand that high fevers red rashes
particularly in your child you may need
to contact your health care provider
there are treatments for this they work
very effectively if if gotten early at
least for the vast majority of the cases
we're studying that very closely and
it's been on the radar for weeks
actually because we've seen this for
quite a while but it's been very rare
but we're we're looking at it very
closely it's very important to us I
think one of the things were most proud
of is this just came out deaths per
100,000 people death so deaths per
100,000 people Germany and the United
States are at the lowest rung of that
ladder meaning low is a positive not a
negative Germany to the United States
are the two best in deaths per 100,000
people which frankly to me that's
perhaps the most important number there
is please go in the back please
thank you Thank You mr. president
I have a two questions one on the amount
a briefcase and one on
the corona virus the first on the corona
virus the president the vice president
is said to be in some sort of self
isolating keeping his difference from
people what do you say to Americans who
say how can you how can you keep me safe
how can you reopen the government if
even the vice president is self
isolating and why hasn't testing gotten
up to to the point where every mayor
American who wants a test can get a test
well the vice president of all has been
tested and he's negative and it was
tested yesterday tested today and he's
negative
he's a very good shape and I think that
that's going to be fine as far as
Americans getting a test they should all
be able to get a test right now if they
should be able to get a test that's the
problem with a question like that
we go through a whole announcement
saying when number one in the world by
far by a factor of two and even three
and four depending on where you're
looking and I get a question when will
everybody be able to get tested if
somebody wants to be tested right now
they'll be able to be tested as far as
the incident of the attorney I think
it's horrible and it's certainly being
looked at by many people I'm speaking of
many people about it
he looked I saw the picture of him in
his tuxedo it was so beautiful I bet he
looks like a a wonderful young guy would
have been a wonderful I mean just a
wonderful guy I think it's a horrible
thing I think it's a horrible thing now
with that being said as you know they're
studying the case very carefully they're
interviewing everybody involved and
we'll see what happens to me it's a very
sad thing I spoke to a number of people
that are very much involved in it I've
been following that one very closely it
breaks your heart to watch it it breaks
your heart
and certainly the video was a was a
terrible looking video to me but you
have a lot of people looking at it and
hopefully an answer is going to be
arrived at very quickly but it's
something that is heartbreaking any
question about the case if I could ask
it and then the specific question I have
is you said that there possibly are
things that happen that that were not
recorded
tape could you know it's expound on what
you mean by that and your thoughts on
well I saw the tape and when they moved
left
I don't believe when they moved left
outside of the tape nobody saw what was
going on nobody saw it's an empty spot
on the tape I guess now do they have
additional tapes I hope but I will say
that it's something that based on what I
saw does it look good somebody that I
have a lot of respect for is Senator
Scott of South Carolina you know who I'm
talking about he's a great gentleman
he's a great senator is a great
gentleman Tim Scott and I called him two
days ago I said Tim what do you think
tell me what do you think he's very
disturbed by it he's very disturbed and
I'm very disturbed also please go ahead
president Trump thank you I have two
questions one on testing and one on
democratic states that you've tweeted
about first the money for this new
testing support today comes from the
Care Act cares Act which you signed into
law 42 days ago did your delay and
embracing widespread testing have
anything to do with a desire to suppress
the official number of US cases and
deaths as you try to reopen the country
no we just wanted to make sure that we
had the proper machinery apparatus and
everything else out there before people
started wasting money so method of
saving money we want to make sure we had
even things like this plus they have
machines that are far more complex than
this they have massive machines at some
of the laboratories that can do millions
of tests we want to make sure everything
was in place okay go ahead and earlier
today you tweeted that Democrats are
moving slowly for political purposes
why do you believe that their motive is
politics rather than Public Safety and
how do you respond to criticism that
you're also motivated by politics to try
to grow the economy ahead of the
election well I think that if you look
at Pennsylvania as an example if you
look at various other states I won't get
into them the people want to go back the
numbers are getting to a point where
they can and it just seems to be no
effort on certain blue states to get
back into gear and the people aren't
going to stand for it they want to get
back
they're not gonna stand for it they want
our country open I want our country open
too I want it open safely but I want it
open don't forget people are dying the
other route you can go with the enclosed
route everything's closed up you're in
your house you're not allowed to move
people are dying with that too you look
at drug addiction you look at suicides
you look at some of the things that are
taking place people are dying that way
too you could make the case it's in even
greater numbers so it's a it's a
situation that some people and I've
noticed that some states could be moving
more quickly and also at the same time
safety look safety is paramount but
people are dying in the lockdown
position too and everybody understands
that they're just starting to find out
and look at what's going on with drugs
and look at what's happening with
suicides you know please please go ahead
so Americans have been self quarantine
for several months now social distancing
yet we're still seeing about 20,000 new
cases a day one to two thousand deaths
is there anything else the
administration is planning to do to get
these new cases under control because we
seem to be on a plateau well excuse me
there 20,000 the numbers are way down
from what they were two weeks ago I mean
the numbers are really coming down and
very substantially this weekend was one
of the lowest we've had this is you know
the numbers are coming down very rapidly
all throughout the country by the way
there may be one exception but all
throughout the country the numbers are
coming down rapidly I think you see that
Admiral now 130,000 cases that go
through August if that do you agree with
those models is that your expectation
well the models haven't been exactly
accurate these are models done by a lot
of think tanks a lot of universities you
look at some of the models they've been
way up a few of the models have been
accurate but as far as the models are
concerned if you go by the model we were
going to lose 2.2 million people and
because we took we mitigated we did
things that we're very
for our country to do frankly we had to
turn off our whole magnificent economy
we had to turn down the whole country
we're at the lowest of all of the models
I mean if you look at I guess that 120
100 to 120 thousand people would be at
the low side and we're at
there's nothing low look nothing low one
is too many people and I say it all the
time one person to lose for this is too
many people it's a disgrace what
happened but if you look at the models
we're at at alone at the lowest of those
projections but the models are not
models done necessarily by the White
House they're models done by many people
all over the world and if you take the
most respected of those people many of
those models are wrong I mean they've
been wrong as far as the u.s. is
concerned because those numbers are
nowhere near what was projected
potentially expectation of what the
death toll is gonna look like by the
summer by there you know what I don't
want to think about it even I know that
we're doing everything we can we're
doing a good job we acted very early we
acted extremely early in keeping China
out of our country and banning people
from China coming in other than our
citizens which we obviously had to take
and they were quarantined or watch
carefully they were tested they will
watch very carefully but we had about
40,000 people coming in from China from
Asia and we had to obviously take the
people can you imagine how I said you're
a US citizen we're not going to take you
that doesn't work so but they were very
carefully I was with Ron dissent as he
said they put literally put the people
that came in from China in quarantine
for a substantial period of time no that
was a big decision I think we saved
hundreds of thousands of lives by acting
very early and when I did this I think
the Admiral can say it everybody was
against my doing and everybody everybody
was the professionals the doctors I was
pretty much by myself on that one and it
was a lucky thing we did it because we
saved hundreds of thousands of lives
yeah plays good
Thank You mr. president earlier today
the vice president urged governor's to
have all their nursing home residents
tested why not just mandate that why not
require that have you considered that
well I would certainly consider that I
will mandate it if you'd like I would I
think it's important to do and I think
frankly some of the governor's were very
lacks with respect to nursing homes it
was obvious right from the beginning the
state of Washington where 26 or 28
people died very early on and I would
have said nursing homes and I did say
nursing homes that's what they should
now some of the states many of the
states are doing that but I think all of
the states should be they have the
capacity to do what they should be doing
nursing home that is a real
vulnerability the two staffers that were
announced last week as testing positive
are you aware of any additional White
House staff no not at all
I'm only aware of people that saw them
were tested the tests were negative and
they're quarantining anyway so please go
ahead I wanted to ask are you now or are
you considering separating some more
with Vice President Prince as a
precautionary measure well first of all
the job he's done on task force the job
he's done frankly as the vice president
of the United States has been
outstanding and he's a warrior too just
like doctors and nurses I mean he is
working so hard and he's coming into
contact with a lot of people but again
he tested negative so we have to
understand that but he comes into
contact with a lot of people it's
something probably during this
quarantine period we'll probably talk
about I have not seen him since then but
I would say that he will he and I will
be talking about that yeah we can talk
on the phone if I could the president
just said that doctor foul Chi dr. Han
have tested negative then why do they
need to be isolated is there some
concern that they could be spreading the
virus in some ways
our concern about the testing why do
they need to ISIL so this is a very
fundamental concept and I'm so happy you
brought that up because it underlies a
lot of the questions here if you test
negative just at that one point that
just means you've tested negative for
that point in time we know that the
incubation period for this virus can be
many days so the CDC guidelines really
says that if you're in close contact
just testing negative on that one day
doesn't mean you won't be positive later
on so the prudent and the recommended
thing to do is to self isolate yourself
for the entire period of incubation and
really then some so that's what they're
doing it's a precautionary manner
because they were negative we all hope
that they remain negative but if they
turn positive in a day or two or became
symptomatic that's still possible even
with a negative test okay
mr. president and one of your mother's
day tweets you appear to accuse
president Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history by far those
were your words
what crime exactly are you accusing
President Obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even got elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now all of this information that's
being released and from what I
understand that's only the beginning
some terrible things happened and it
should never be allowed to happen in our
country again and you'll be seeing
what's going on over the next over the
coming weeks but and I wish you'd write
honestly about it but unfortunately you
choose not to do so yeah gently what if
the crime exactly then you think you
know what the crime is the crime is very
obvious to everybody all you have to do
is read the newspapers except yours John
please if I can just get a clarification
on the on the testing we've seen clearly
that the numbers of tests of going up
there been some advancements in testing
but you said twice or today that every
American who wants a test can get a test
yes
that's not the case 1.9 million tests
per day is far short of every American
that wants a test to be able to I didn't
have the advil but I will say just from
listening and hearing like you do we all
do not everybody should get a test
because they have to have certain things
and they're going to know when they're
not feeling right those are the people
that will be getting the tests but I'd
well let you take it from there please
so everybody who needs a test can get a
test we have plenty of tests for that
right right now in America anybody who
needs a test can get a test in America
with the numbers we have if you are
symptomatic with a respiratory illness
that is an indication for a test and you
can get a test if you need to be contact
traced you can get a test and we hope
and not hope we are starting to have a
symptomatic surveillance which is very
important again that's over 3 million
tests per week that is sufficient for
everyone who needs a test symptomatic
contact tracing and to our best project
the asymptomatic kind of surveillance we
need to get that and that that's the way
it is and remember um I I work at HHS
I work there every day I don't get
tested every day um I get monitored for
my symptoms am i febrile
do I have any other symptoms I wear a
mask when I go in that's a safe work
environment for the environment we have
if I became symptomatic I would get a
test and if it were positive I would
isolate and there'd be contact tracing
to stop that just the way it was done
here if I'm not symptomatic I do the
precautions as everyone is recommended
in phase one and that's the essence of
safe to safely opening America and John
the numbers are coming way down and
they're coming down rapidly and that's a
beautiful thing to see and that's pretty
much universally all across the country
they're coming down very rapidly so very
important please go ahead animal if so
so Americans who are going back to work
shouldn't expect and shouldn't need
shouldn't want to have the same thing
that people coming to work here at the
White House have which is the ability to
get tested regularly regardless of
symptoms so let me clarify as well
people who come into close contact with
the president get tested on a regular
basis okay if I were not in close
contact with the president specifically
I would not get tested like most people
here do not get tested that's a very
specific circumstance when I work at HHS
I go at HHS I don't get tested I do the
exact thing that we asked Americans to
do to monitor your symptoms if you are
symptomatic self isolate get tested or
whether our community-based testing
sites at your hospitals their even at
home testing now that has been
authorized and and to cooperate that if
you need to be contact traced be contact
trace and cooperate with your local
public health but not everybody who
walks in here gets tested every time
they do if you're symptomatic here at
HHS at a meatpacking plant at a school
you need to get tested and that
meatpacking plants now are doing very
well there's great testing around those
plants and we're finding out who had the
problem they're being quarantined and
the Meatpacking is moving along very
nicely but they were they were trouble
spots they were hot zones definitely
please and you know one thing I think
it's very important that John just to
finish we have now and nobody says it
they just don't want to write it by far
more tests than any other country in the
world not even a contest and the quality
of our test is the best anywhere in the
world that's very important to say
please go ahead to make sure I
understand the White House's position
are you saying that right now you feel
there is enough testing out of quit
testing across the United States or do
you feel that it needs to be ramped up
and by how much if so does it need to be
arranged up we've been I think we've
been clear all along that we believe in
the data indicate we have enough testing
to do the phase one gradually we
reopening that has been supported in the
in the president's plan and the task
force plan and it has to be a phased
reopening nobody's saying turn the light
switch on and everyone go because then
it would be really impossible to control
the spread the spread of the virus you
know there are many many models out
there the Rockefeller Foundation
published as their recommendations of
about three million tests per week
that's exactly what we're doing if you
look at our agent based models it's far
below that if you take the Safra Center
at Harvard and correct their Mis
assumptions like on the sensitivity of
the test the mitigation processes and
how many people get hospitalized you get
about that number now I am NOT going to
come here and say we can absolutely
swear it's God's truth that this is the
number we need but we know we have
enough to open and we're gonna be very
careful with our ili net with our
surveillance programs and what the data
come in to inform us even further as we
grow and learn a little bit cuz most
days I don't come to the White House to
work I either go to FEMA or I go to HHS
and let me just talk you through what
the protocols are there because I would
never get tested if I wasn't coming to
the White House so every day when we
come in we get our temperature taken and
we get asked questions about if we have
symptoms if you don't then you enter the
workplace and then there's hand
sanitizer all over the place in rooms
that are made for conference rooms they
put pieces of paper there
say don't sit in essentially every other
every third seat to separate people and
so there's a lot of precautions that
we're taking in the federal government
that are separate from testing and those
are the precautions that the agencies
that Admiral Gerar and I are working at
every day are using to let us continue
working if people want to get tested
they get tested we have the greatest
capacity in the world not even close if
people want to get tested they get
tested but for the most part they
shouldn't want to get tested there's no
reason that they feel good they don't
have sniffles they don't have sore
throats they don't have any problem if
they do feel there's something happening
they have the absolute easy in fact
Rhonda Santos of Florida the governor's
doing a fantastic job in Florida he said
he's got a little bit of the opposite
problem he's got so much testing that
people sit around and wait for people to
come in that they have far a great over
capacity for testing and there are
numerous other states that have told me
the same thing that's by the way a good
problem not a bad problem okay yeah go
ahead please many times that the u.s. is
doing far better than any other country
when it comes to testing yes why does
that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if everyday Americans are still losing
their lives and we're still seeing more
cases every day well they're losing
their lives everywhere in the world and
maybe that's a question you should ask
China
don't ask me has China that question
okay when you ask them that question you
may get a very unusual answer yes behind
you please sir why are you saying that
to me
specifically I'm telling you I'm not
saying it specifically to anybody I'm
saying it to anybody that would ask a
nasty question like that please go ahead
okay anybody else please go ahead in the
back please no it's okay
I have two questions mister next next
place but you didn't you called on me I
did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on the young lady in the back
please ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much appreciate it thank you very
much